hey I was going everyone my name is
Pierre and I just want to say a quick
thank you I guess Li this was my hundred
hundreds of the video I was actually
gonna make like thank you for 2004 all
it was 1000 subs and then I postponed it
and then it got to 2000 subs and then I
postponed it and then it's like two two
thousand five hundred subs like I never
really been like I I don't really care
for numbers that much what I care more
about is the support for that I get from
all you guys that means so much more
than just a random number but I just
thought I'd drop by say hello and really
say thank you it means a lot to me I
love making these videos and you guys
are my main motivation of wanting to
make these videos so yeah thanks again
this is just a quick thank you video
hope you have a nice evening day morning
or whatever and this is beautiful
signing off alright so a funny thing I
just realized that basically a friend of
mine had he has begged me for I have no
idea how long and you've not wanted me
to make a setup video a lot of you guys
have actually asked me to do a setup
video as well so I thought why the
not
I just got a turn on the lights here
this is my apartment
it's really luxurious for my standard at
least I can barely afford to pay the
rent and and you know if I show my
computer and all that you're probably
you're gonna think oh man this guy's
guys its rich he's got a lot of money
but truth be told I am I basically spent
all my money on this baby right hey for
those of you don't know this like I paid
for this computer basically by doing
artwork in Photoshop I used my tablet
tabloid or whatever it's called
surprisingly enough people like my
paintings but anyway
let's just open this baby up I call her
a Swedish name she goes by the name of
Beth thumb
she's just magnificent okay the case is
actually as I can do this with one
hand the case is actually Swedish
manufacturer oh god I'm not I'm sorry if
you're like motion sick or something
I'm actually really easy to motion
sickness I get motion 6-1-6 sick when I
Drive my own car and you can't see
anything let's see if I can hold on just
a second god damnit you coming with me
oh god there's like cords everywhere
oh that only girl
oh boy I know your lamp is that work I
can't put it on this other side he's
gotta be a mess later but anyway okay
where I must earth actually have all my
specs on on my channel description but
basically I don't know if there's like
much to comment on that that I think
about it this right here is a
solid-state drive I can really recommend
one of those the computer boots like in
I don't why I feel this you know this
item but it boots like in just a couple
of seconds awesome I'm actually
uploading a video right now so I don't
think I can restart my computer just yet
but anyway this is a 1080p screen it was
pretty cheap actually got it for a great
price
Microsoft keyboard Microsoft Mouse and
miles pad or whatever it's stiff
that's what I wanted to show with that
headphones are razor Karachi's you can
probably sell about that I like the
color black I think it looks sweet on
hardware um I don't know I guess that's
it I thought I was gonna make like a Q&A
video cuz I got a lot of questions
recent
they so if you all just leave leave a
question in the comments and I'll answer
it in my next video this is Pete about
signing out for the second time